but bigger the better first of all big  action big visual effects this is a  big-screen movie I like right in my face  what better than Ryan Reynolds right  here so gross a lot of artists have  worked their ass off to really make it  work in big scale you get a bigger  screen for bigger lives a grand  presentation that Marvel movies are  comedy for me works better in that way  funny it's full of action it's really  hot so it's an antic and full of okay  Deadpool 2 was like the Canadian version  of couples retreat with slightly less  Malin Akerman more like sugar raise  every morning but with slightly more  mark McGrath stop making out of contact  with me we're pushing the boundaries to  grab the fresh air it makes me laugh  every time I see it collapsing to the  floor how funny it is  it's like a family film it but don't  take your kids  [Music]